I don't think artists talk about
integrity that much it's just sort of a
given you don't have much to hang your
hat on other than your personal
integrity and you know and and and what
you and what you do you know I don't
think there are charlatans out there if
you want to be a charlatan if you want
to pull the wool over the eyes of public
there's a lot better ways to do it and a
lot more money to be made then by trying
to do it through art look at that Bernie
Madoff sand the other people in the
world you know who you know are real
cheats who are really fooling people and
and lying to them this is not a
profession that particular is
particularly well suited you know for a
sham and and it's not a game of
three-card Monte you know it's so
there's magic to it but it's not you're
not trying to fool the public so I think
you know one can question what certain
artists have done the the whether or not
it was a good idea or a bad idea or you
might wonder why they shouldn't just get
their head examined but I you know I
take them seriously and I know anybody
who calls themselves an artist and what
they make is art as far as I'm concerned
it may it should only thing I can decide
is if it's relevant to me and if it has
meaning to me and and if I find value in
it but I'm not going to question the
integrity of the person who you know
who's
put it out